ok today we're going to learn about
specific heat capacity we're going to
learn what specific heat capacity
actually means we're gonna have a look
at the equation to do with specific heat
capacity and we're gonna have a look at
an experiment in order to find the
specific heat capacity of a liquid so
let's just imagine this let's say I have
got two substances here this first one
here is water and this substance here is
liquid well mercury which is a liquid
metal but it's liquid at room
temperature let's say I've got a
kilogram of each of them so what
specific heat capacity actually means is
how much thermal energy is required in
order to raise one kilogram of this by
one degree Celsius now what that means
is this let's say I'm applying thermal
energy to both of these so heating both
of these up now because these substances
of different substances from each other
they're going to take a different amount
of thermal energy in order to raise the
temperature by one degree Celsius so
water would actually require 4200 joules
of thermal energy whereas mercury would
only require a hundred and thirty-nine
jewels in order to raise that kilogram
by one degree Celsius so that is
essentially what specific heat capacity
actually means how much thermal energy
is required to raise one kilogram of
that substance by one degree Celsius and
every every different substance will
have a different specific heat capacity
now there's an equation that we need to
be able to know and use in order to
determine specific heat capacity so the
change in thermal energy equals the mass
so that's of the mass of the liquid that
we're dealing with times the specific
heat capacity that's the thing we may
well be looking for times the
temperature
so how much temperatures risen by so
what we're going to do now is we are
going to have a look at an experiment
that we could do in order to find the
specific heat capacity of a liquid so
let's say I've got the first thing I
need to do is I get my container and I'm
going to put it on an electronic balance
so let's say at the beginning my
electronic balance it reads a hundred
grams so that's without the substance in
it so that's my electronic balance says
that weighs sorry that has a mass of 100
grams so what I do do next is I add my
substance so my my liquid and let's say
now this has a mass of a hundred and
fifty grams so in order to find the mass
of just this liquid here what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do 150 minus 100
which gives me an answer of 50 grams
okay so that's my first step what I'm
then going to do is I take my container
because I'm going to do this experiment
to find the specific heat capacity of
this particular substance so what I need
to do is I'm going to put a lid over the
top of it to prevent heat loss by
convection I'm also gonna have a
thermometer in there because this
thermometer is going to read my
temperature change and I'm also going to
be using this thing called a Joule meter
so what my dual meat is doing is my dual
meter is actually connected to to an
electric immersion heater so all it is
is this heater which goes into the
liquid and then I'll be able to on my
dual me to see how much thermal energy
has gone into this immersion heater here
okay so for my experiment what I need to
do is I need to pick a sensible
temperature rise to look up so let's say
degrees Celsius would be a sensible
amount of a sensible temperature change
so what I need to do is allow my
temperature change four to ten degrees
Celsius and then on my joulemeter I read
how many joules it's taken in order to
raise that by 10 degrees Celsius so
let's say for sake of argument it took a
thousand joules to raise this liquid by
10 degrees C so now I've got everything
that I need in order to try and find the
specific heat capacity of this substance
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
gonna write down these different parts
so first of all my change in thermal
energy well that there is on my jewel
meter so it's a thousand joules so that
equals the mass now my mass is the mass
of this liquid here but please notice
that needs to be in kilograms where's
all my balance it may well have read it
in grams so divided from grams to
kilograms I need to divide by a thousand
so in this case it's 0.05 kilograms so
it's a thousand equals 0.05 times by see
that's my specific heat capacity that's
the thing I'm looking to try and find
and finally multiplied by my temperature
change and my temperature change is the
one that I chose which is 10 so what I
need to do now is I need to get C all by
itself because if I can rearrange this
equation if I could rearrange this
equation to make C the subject then I'm
laughing so um what I'm going to do
first of all is I'm just going to
simplify it so I've got a thousand here
I'm going to multiply these two numbers
together to begin with to make it easier
so thousand equals 0.5 times C all I've
done is multiplied those two numbers
together now I still haven't got C but
all by itself so what I'm going to do is
I need to make sure I'm do the same
thing to both
the equation I'm going to divide this
side by 0.5 because at the moment it's
timed by 0.5 and I'm going to divide
this side by 0.5 so let's just have a
look a thousand divided by 0.5 equals
2000 so that is my specific heat
capacity of this substance just going to
rewrite like this so C equals 2000 now
specific heat capacity has a bit of a
strange unit its joules per kilogram
degree Celsius so that is the specific
heat capacity of this particular
substance
so just to recap specific heat capacity
is the thermal energy required in order
to raise the temperature of a sub one
kilogram for substance by one degree
Celsius this is the equipment that you
need in order to find the specific heat
capacity of a substance here is the
equation for specific heat capacity and
this is how you use the numbers from
your experiment in order to determine it
thank you very much